so this is our exciting day because we
are officially starting the gay to lease
journalism course traditionally we've
understood journalism and research as
this method of just collecting
information organizing it and then
expressing it
but then Along came a man named gay
police and he transformed journalism it
transformed the way we understood
research
okay so we created something called
literary
journalism
which is the idea that journalism can be
by itself be literature the gate release
method is going to teach us how to be
creative how to be imaginative
and how to
engage with reality and engage with
people because we don't teach you this
in school in fact we teach you the
opposite don't explore just do what the
teacher tells you to do we need to learn
this well he learned this at home
the reason why is that his father
was a tailor
and his father was a tailor
and he had a
tailoring business in New Jersey and his
mother
took care of the business well his
father made the close
okay so what does it have to do with
exploration and reflection
well
his mother was responsible for the
business aspects so these very wealthy
people would come to the shop
and order very nice suits
um and her job was to deal with them but
it's actually very hard to deal with
rich people they make me very demanding
so her strategy was to become their
friend
and how to become someone's friend what
do you do in order to become someone's
friend what must you do
wrong
not talk they have to pay officer
listen Okay you understand
so
a family living room the mother would
just sit down on the couch talking
with these very wealthy people
and she would talk just by listening
okay so her strategy for this is that
I am interested
in you
so that's how she became friends with
all these very wealthy people even
though she herself was that wealthy
because she had a mindset
that whoever she whoever came into her
living room whoever was a client
was first and foremost a friend and she
want she was interested in this person
she was interested in people so she
would spend hours and hours just
listening that person talk and talk and
talk
and so you can say that this is
exploration
okay
curiosity
okay exploration
but in the other room the father would
by himself sit and work on the clothes
right I'm not sure if you've seen
Taylor's work but they are very precise
they are very exact they are very
meticulous
they're very disciplined they're very
patient so you could spend days and days
in his room just working on a piece of
suit
right this is the idea of reflection
of perfection
so exploration is the pursuit of
curiosity
and reflection is a pursuit of
perfection
this is the gay to lease this is the gay
to lease
research method this is what I'll be
teaching you this is something that will
not just help you become a better writer
but someone who will be much more
creative and a much more effective
researcher so even if you are going to a
Sciences I guarantee you that the skills
you'll be learning in this class will
help you
um Wherever You Go I want you to go
around paging and take pictures again
the idea is contrast remember that here
he says New York is a city of things
unnoticed New York is a city of contrast
I want you to I want you to do the same
thing for Beijing take your camera and
take pictures of things that other
people would not notice okay and take
pictures of things that are contrast of
each other